the cold war was filled with civil wars
and revolutions and normally those civil
wars would see the u.s led west on one
side with the communist world on the
other but when the nigerian civil war
kicked off in 1967 and saw this region
break away as the republic of biafra the
sides were much less clear the nigerian
government was backed by the uk the usa
sort of the ussr and israel whereas
biafra was backed by the people's
republic of china france and also israel
and given that both sides were such a
confusing mess this raises an obvious
question what on earth happened why did
the nigerian civil war have such weird
sides so like many conflicts in africa
during the cold war the roots of the
nigerian civil war can be traced back to
the end of colonial rule there nigeria
gained its independence from britain in
1963 and it was a very diverse country
made up of many different peoples whom
britain clumped together because it made
the map look nicer in the north the
largest region in the country the house
of fulani people were dominant and they
were the ones who made up the majority
of nigeria's military and were
predominantly muslim the yaruba were the
largest group in the southwest and they
were the wealthiest in their region
house nigeria's current capital and the
south east was mostly made up of the
iguo people whose land was home to much
of nigeria's massive oil reserves long
story short after britain left the three
groups couldn't decide on where the
capital would stay how much autonomy
everyone would get and who would be
allowed into the army in 1966 there was
a military coup shortly followed by a
counter coup and honestly a lot of
people were purged ethnic violence
exploded and hundreds of thousands of
igbo people fled to the south east and
leaders there opted to break away in
1967. the nigerian leadership didn't
accept this and so civil war so why were
the supporters of each side so varied
well the main supporter of the nigerian
government was britain who as their
former colonial overlord felt
passionately about the well-being of the
nigerian state and just kidding it was
oil british companies controlled about
90 of nigeria's oil production most of
which went to britain and if the biafran
republic had gained its independence it
may have lost said oil as such the
british provided lots of guns and lots
of money to the lagos government the us
government wasn't too keen on all of the
murder going on but it wanted to support
britain which meant not really getting
involved and despite america's empathy
for the igbo if biafra seceded it could
have potentially led to other movements
bringing up across africa and civil wars
tended to see communist support rise
which meant that biafra would get no
help from the usa like its rivals the
soviet government also supported nigeria
not for any moral reasons but for
political and economic ones the nigerian
government was looking for some planes
which the ussr certainly had to spare
and since britain had refused to provide
them that meant that there was money to
be made it was also hoped that help in
the civil war would improve relations
with nigeria which was one of the most
influential nations on the continent
however the soviets had to be smart
about their support since if they became
too influential in nigeria they knew
that the americans would get involved as
such they pressured britain to provide
more military aid by threatening to do
it themselves if they refused this was a
bluff since they didn't actually want to
do this but it allowed britain to
believe that they were fighting
communism in africa when in fact their
continued support was keeping the united
states uninvolved by making it look like
the soviets were failing to win
influence in nigeria as for biafra they
had three main material supporters
france china and israel france supported
the igbo mostly because of their deep
concern for their well-being and oh wait
no it was also oil france much like
britain had oil companies in the region
and if biafra managed to break away
france could have got some of it
nigerian victory also worried the french
government who saw nigeria as being too
large and populous there were concerns
that a successful nigeria could
influence france's former colonies
around it and diminish its clout in the
region as for china they had just had a
very public falling out with the soviet
union and since the ussr was backing
nigeria china had to do the opposite and
so funneled arms to biafra it also
helped china in trying to establish
itself as an independent communist
leader with his own reach and influence
across the world the last country which
was deeply involved was israel israel
was in a tough spot since politically
siding with the nigerian government
would have helped to improve relations
with the rest of the continent since up
until this point the vast majority of
independent african states opposed
israel due to the palestine conflict
domestically though the israeli people
supported the igbo and so israel's
government opted to help both in the end
the support for biafra did little and in
1970 it was recaptured and formally
reintegrated into nigeria and after this
the nigerian civil war would not only be
remembered for its brutality but also
the peculiar sides that the rest of the
world took in the conflict
i hope you enjoyed this episode and
thank you for watching with a special
thanks to my patrons james bissonette
kelly moneymaker corso wolff jordan
longley adam stalter jerry lambda marcus
arsenaulian hockey words about books
podcast rodney martin captain cydog
marvin cassel gustav swann spencer
lightfoot boogerly wuggley common yoon
winston k wood aaron the white matthew
shipley alex schwinn max and flaudio
maggie patzkowski anthony beckett the
mcquapper corey turner coppertone
spinning through plates charles the
first ben evanson and scottish trekkie